[Music]
it's another beautiful day guys it's
5:00 in the morning and go do a little
catfishing poor Tom he's still asleep
that boy really needs to sleep so I'm
gonna let him go for it and just go
fishing for a few hours and then
afterwards we're gonna have serious fun
well here I am at that River spot me and
Tommy we're kicking out yesterday
morning just about three hours earlier I
don't care what country you're in a
spillway is an awesome place to fish
all right I'm going to set up my
dialogue rod first this is about an
eight footer two point seven meter rod
but it is a good-looking rod look at
that
this is a newer version of the Liberty
Club dialogues I have owned a couple of
the old silver Liberty clubbed Iowa
I have loved them and used them for
catfish and carp for a number of years
so I came here I grabbed the newer
models which I think are made out of
better material a little bit more
carbon-fiber
I also got this brand new dialog reel to
deal with it is that die wash saltwater
reel it's got the mag seal on it so that
water can't get into the ball bearings
dirt sand and stuff can't get in there
oh man look at that
that thing is as smooth as butter that
is a gorgeous reel yeah that is a
good-looking combo I got some Japanese I
think it's called g-force or something
with braided line this is the thinnest
braid I've ever felt in my life
here we go a very traditional spillway
rig a disk sinker a dropper loop above
that the one ought circle hook a little
bit of sardine
let that sit and see if Japanese catfish
like sardines this is my Japanese cat
fishing rod it's from a company called
soul fiesta and this is namazu right
there and it's a lure rod it's got a
split handle it's a medium power rod so
this right here is the Shimano scorpion
DC it's a low-profile reel with an
automatic drag system so apparently it
doesn't need to be adjusted for the
Scott auto drag on it you simply tell it
what type of line you're using in this
case braid and and then it's off to the
races you can't adjust it but it's a
very light reel well I bought like 30
bucks worth of cat fishing lures
yesterday like an idiot I left them all
at the hotel so instead I've got a
bobber a split shot a j-hook a little
bit of sardine well I haven't seen any
nibbles or any signs of catfish yet but
I can see
to carp one about six pounds and one
about ten pounds holy mackerel there's a
giant salamander down there right there
the things three feet long he stuck his
head out of the water and looked at me
and I thought it was an alligator
it's a giant Japanese salamander I've
heard about these these are the largest
salamanders in the world I didn't have a
clue they'd be here oh my gosh that
thing was like a dragon as long as that
carp I caught yesterday he's just living
down there in those rocks well I've been
here for about two hours and I haven't
gotten a single bite seen a lot of carp
though and a giant freaking salamander
so that was cool I think what I'll do is
back it up for today and maybe tomorrow
come back here with some carp bait and
carp rigs and see how that works out
Becca's offshore conference and I've got
Tommy here and we are gonna go to our
Ashima to go see monkeys and other stuff
all right got a parking spot for our
bicycle let's get on the train now you
want a Pikachu soda hit the blue button
under Pikachu
it's the pokemons carried in apple juice
threat
that's the platform for the Shinkansen
the bullet train
things like 100 and something miles per
hour it's a great way great way to
travel within the country just because
it's not as time consuming as going
through to an airport and getting
through security and all that stuff but
it's pretty darn fast
[Music]
right now hike in this
don't touch him remember don't pick him
up don't touch him top they'll bite
[Music]
see the mommy she doesn't like she
doesn't like other people near her baby
poor here
one monkey was scratching his bottom
just the key
[Applause]
[Music]
got a pretty awesome view of Coco way
off there in the distance that's kyoto
tower kill it though okie right over
there here you want to go down to the
playground Tom see you let me go I'll be
go fast
okay just go normal to be dead retains
your mind twice in five seconds in you
[Music]
[Applause]
saw some monkeys they freak Tommy out a
little bit
we got a feed a few I got to tell you
though I don't blame Tommy for being a
little freaked out by the monkeys my
uncle gene had a pet monkey and it bit
his ear off so yeah you know
okay here we go we got melon cider
classic original v2e cider so me - yeah
means three arrows you can see their
logo and Mitsubishi the car needs three
diamonds kind of similar meteor cider is
kind of like 7up but a little bit more
fruity yeah that was good times all
right man shall we go go let's find a
rickshaw maybe go do a little
sightseeing
while we were here in Japan is we got
the tail end of a massive flood that
killed like 170 people Adi actually Yama
is a little bit closer to where that was
really the worst you can see the river
still high and muddy up here hit the
rickshaw
there we go there's the bathroom it's
like riding a bicycle
never forget out well we loved doing
that rickshaw ride in Kyoto and we're
tired after riding up to the monkey park
so this this guy is gonna take us around
we're gonna do a little sightseeing
here I go first time up you go buddy
cities ski disco da was selenium eto oh
boy oh dem boobs a mosquito get an idea
to the tech area oh so so so true it's a
thatched roof house Kumamoto to Nagasaki
tofudan the whole day soon de Dutch
cochinita what's the ROI daisuki design
a keyguard sakhiwe Ichiban Nagar in the
Maya
Arturo Minami SOC mrs. maretto Sato
Hawks week oogie oogie the pond Anarkali
eat cheap on the Corina - there's a
one-star Michelin unagi don't shop
that's my jam right there
[Music]
that makes it amazing there you go Tom's
got a fan he's got a cold water on the
back of his neck it's good it's good to
be a five-year-old sometimes his old
temple built by the shogun tokugawa
shogun and not a single nail in there
I'll put together using joints I love
Japanese gardens they've got some really
this is a fun way to see the city it's
you know relaxing but it's more up close
and personal than a car and these guys
who pull these rickshaws impressive me
yeah makes me realize I need to go to
the gym or Yetta what's your what's your
favorite samurai movie
[Music]
[Laughter]
that rickshaw ride was fun we had a good
time okonomiyaki yes uh
[Music]
all right so this place where they have
some okonomiyaki which is like a
Japanese penny that they cook on the
table in front of it so this is gonna be
good
I've been wanting this for a couple days
now check it out we got some yakisoba
here and we okonomiyaki it's a pancake
kind of like thing only it's got like
cabbage and vegetables and egg and
ginger and meat in there someone's got
beef some have squid and they put bonito
flakes on it mayonnaise soy sauce and a
little bit of seaweed to that I love
okonomiyaki it is so good
Tommy's eating something other than ice
cream
[Music]
oh we got ourselves some food let's do a
little shopping for mom and Nathan and
Jacob yeah yeah spider crab that's right
oh you could've discussed he's giving
you a present it's a real owl and you
can touch him checked it watch this just
on the back like that there's it's very
gentle see he's okay he didn't mind that
no no you gotta totally bite me that's a
barn owls
that's from Virginia
uou try that one
okay hold still I don't think I want to
try this one nope nope not trying that
one Koli touched you anyways haha
wait don't up he's taking a break see
his assignment he's a who touch me let's
do in say hello hello my name is Tommy
the owl
[Music]
[Applause]
alright we're getting the slightly
overpriced talking animals got them yeah
these umbrellas
there's samurai swords see get a pretty
handkerchief for Mom it's a little salty
but not bad it's nice and cold then it's
a vegetable which I haven't eaten in a
while
no idea what that is
so giggles peekaboo miracle hoarding go
milk and orange I think is what that
says a little bit
save a town there's a bicycle
[Music]
well guys now it was pretty fun I am
tired and sweaty and my backpack is full
of souvenirs so we're gonna head back to
the house see if we can get in touch
with Beckett and go figure out something
to do for the rest of the day we got
home and Becca is still not back from
her conference here and we're gonna pick
up some carp bait and look around a
little bit two dudes out on the town all
right take it out I got some carp bait
here I've got panco got frozen corn
because they don't sell cam corn and
I've got a loaf of fresh bread and then
I've got strawberry does uh all right
we'll be in Tommy we're gonna get on the
bike we're gonna ride down to the river
we're gonna do some pre baiting go
fishing tomorrow morning probably so I
might throw out my bait and see what
happens I got my bucket of carp bait
here then I add some water to it mix it
up and then I'm gonna check out some
balls of it here to get the carb used to
feed knot it and we'll try fishing for
them tomorrow morning
Tommy where's Tommy what the can you get
down you're alive you did it
Becker got home and we ate some cheapo
bentos and we're turning in very early
it's about 7:00 p.m. we're going to sit
in bed listen to our favorite audiobook
and go get tons of sleep we're only two
weeks into a month-long thing we got to
pace yourself so but tomorrow I'm gonna
try to go catch some of those carp and
I'll see you then if you liked this
video don't forget to check out part six
of our 2018 World Tour where we spent
five weeks traveling the world fishing
and exploring and having a great time so
if you want to see those videos don't
forget to click subscribe to the outdoor
boys YouTube channel I'll put a link in
the description thanks for watching and
have a great day